oh good i would like to give i would i
would like to all the people who are
watching right now
silently in your home start clapping for
james o'keefe just you know because he
he he this is this is maybe one of the
biggest and best stories i think he's
done
probably not true i'm probably
forgetting something more impactful but
uh project veritas
has gotten a cnn staffer on the record
gloating
about covid deaths propping up their
ratings oh boy and he says
the red phone rings and it's jeff zucker
who i believe is the president
calling and saying hey get that death
tracker on the tv
because it's good for the ratings that's
amazing
that's horrible it's amazing but is it
really a shocker yeah
well hold on hold on hold on what's the
shocking part the first
expose that veritas did the other day
where the guy's like we hate trump we
want we got him out of office we're
propaganda i'm like
oh surprise surprise we know this but
still a good job on veritas getting this
information
but when the guys on camera being here's
what he said quote covet
gangbusters with ratings right which is
why we constantly have the death toll
on the side that made my jaw hit the
floor yeah
i didn't i i knew the bar was low for
cnn but come on
he's on a date with a woman going like
gangbusters man covet all these people
dying that's great wow that that that to
me was like
his first what's awesome is the context
if you think about it right
so this guy is on a date exactly
with a girl that swiped on him or
somehow got connected with him
well you know we don't know how they met
uh and they're on a date
and he's bragging to her he's bragging
to her about how they're making you
imaginating the country please tell me
this was the first date too you like
take your lap for a first date you're
like guess what we're doing
hold on hold on first of all not not the
propaganda okay
imagine it's the first date and he goes
when people die
it's great it's like i make so much
money
right but you know the sad part is is he
probably doesn't get a single extra
penny based on on ratings
and he's doing it because he's a
corporate drone and he's selling out his
country and all of his fellow countrymen
so that some corporation and
shareholders can get rich which makes
him double triple loser
oh my god imagine going on a date with a
woman and trying
and thinking you're going to get laid by
bragging about how dead people are good
for your good for money
well here's the other money that if
you're that turns me off
your first tip that this is a spy should
be that you work at cnn and she's going
on a date with you like why
on earth would anyone in their right
mind the whole time he's like this girl
she's like she's really into me why is
she talking to me i don't know i'm just
gonna go maybe it's because i'm work for
cnn she must think that that's amazing
is this woman's twit uh tinder profile
like you know people dying is exciting
to me so he's like
he feels like this is but she's like i
love being lied to he's like
perfect no in the tinder profile it says
i like like
adderall addicted alcoholic balding fat
guys that work inside windowless rooms
all day
that's what i'm looking for so be fair
this guy doesn't look like that
oh all right never mind that but but but
working for cnn puts you on that level i
think is what he's saying sorry i was
just thinking
about working at cnn takes you from like
a 10 to a three yeah the reason why i
take this seriously is because there's
been other there's been other
uh verit veritas exposes where employees
of cnn were actually like
we used to do news this sucks we're
unhappy there was one guy he's like
sitting in a room as an older
middle-aged guy with a big old belly and
he's like we used to actually go out and
report stuff
and i when i saw that expose from
veritas i was like wait a minute
when was the last time you saw cnn do a
live report on the ground at a major
event
and at that point it was like deep in
the trump presidency i was like damn
it's been years
yeah it's been years so this guy's sad
about it
this dude loves imagining the time of
his life
here's the best part though jack you
mentioned it he's not getting a single
extra penny
right for cnn doing well imagine being
like randall from recess you know like
miss finster yeah he's all happy and
bloating like
human suffering makes my company succeed
it's like he's you're not benefiting
from it he just likes watching people
suffer
because it benefits his tribe that's
right and and imagine think it's going
to get you laid
i was thinking back like where in my
brain and how did it get there that cnn
had credibility
and i was trying to that was in there at
some point just just now i was
reflecting
on tim's comments and yes there was a
moment in my pre-awakened state
people are watching man you don't have
to admit that
just stick around for the after show and
uh and so i was like you know what it
was
it was wolf blitzer during the first
iraq war i feel like that to me
like anchored credibility in my mind for
cnn
but knowing what i know now i look back
and i just wonder how much of all that
was complete nonsense in bs the whole
time too yeah a lot of the media first
iraq war media was full yeah
what i've heard from people that
actually served and fought over there
well there were there was this series of
papers that came out about afghan
these like afghanistan papers i've heard
about it which i'm not sure if you guys
have uh heard about these but yeah i
mean we were lied to you from the start
wait hold on when was that was that 2010
or less
this was not as far no
yeah are you talking about did that come
from that russian psychological operator
that guy
on the wiki the wiki wikileaks
wikileaks wikilea
they gave him something worse than a
death sentence in my opinion julian
assange
he was exposing the establishment the
corrupt machine
he uh looked the emails that got that
got released through wikileaks
shined a light on what what the dnc was
doing with these media organizations the
nefarious
uh double standards and all that stuff
and for the for everything that julian
assange has done
they gave him something worse than a
death sentence it's a character
assassination
and an and indeterminate imprisonment a
solution
timeline no hope it's crazy dude the
military industrial complex is the
empire from star wars and if you ever
watch star wars and think what side
would i be on would i be part of the
empire if you don't support julian
assange then you're part of the empire
yep well to be fair we're all sitting in
the death star being like i hate the
death star i dislike this death star
yeah it was so lame how the death star
blew up you know alderaan
miss elliot how did you dismantle him
imagine being the death star doing a
broadcast show we were like
the decimation of alderaan was wrong and
protesting it and then like nothing
changes wait wait wait wait did you say
we're sitting inside the death star
right now yes we're part of the empire
yes i'm confused the the united states
government oh
and then finally we get this like
accident like darth vader accidentally
loses an election somehow he screws up
and then we get some crazy like you know
jabba
a hut guy yeah who's this you know crazy
yeah
yeah trump the trump nationalist becomes
the lead the emperor somehow
and i'm like look the hutts are not good
people but this is better than darth
vader
sidious is out what do we do and then
the empire takes it back and then
and then trump the hutt was like i want
to do good deals
i want to make lots of money blowing up
alderaan isn't good for business
let's move let's let's do peace on
tatooine let's get our troops back
and then the the the imperials the
leadership were like no
no we need to blow up these planets so
you know then darth biden comes in
good old darth vader get it get get the
lights get get the get the lightsaber
rusty put it in the barrel
well speaking of the industrial military
complex and they're lackeys in the media
it's interesting how
cnn and some of these other outlets have
characterized biden extending the
deadline for when we leave
afghanistan so biden says that as a
non-negotiable we're going to be out of
afghanistan by september 11th
oh and they're reporting it as if he
just came in and decided we're gonna
pull our troops out of afghanistan
no trump negotiated a deal with the
taliban where we were supposed to be out
by may 1st so biden extended the
deadline
and they're reporting on it as if biden
just came in and pulled us out ahead of
time
and a lot of it is is negative too
they're saying things like well biden is
doing this against the advice
of foreign policy experts of course we
should stay there lindsey graham
he's like he's making a he's gonna make
another 911.
okay this is as bad as the 100 million
vaccinations in 100 days story
you know where like biden comes in he's
like i'm we're going to change
everything we're doing around here we're
going to do a hundred million vaccines
in a hundred days which was exactly
the trump's the trump plan yeah but now
they're just screwing it up now it's
like he's gonna say
we're gonna do 50 million they're
pushing well that's the thing
so here there has not been uh a single
american troop
killed in afghanistan in a year at this
point but the taliban have said if we
are not out by that may first deadline
that we negotiated they will start
attacking the united states and our nato
allies again
here's my prediction come like may third
or fourth
there's going to be an attack on an
american base and biden's going to be
alike
we have to stay it's clear that they're
not you know willing to allow peace
there's going to be a series of news
about attacks that's exactly what i was
thinking deadline's gonna
so the choreography is in place the
dancers are prepped
yep the music is playing mm-hmm and the
guys at lockheed martin are just going
like this yeah and all
all the world trump had to do to fight
the foreign policy establishment to get
us to the point where we could have a
deal negotiated
where in the near future we'd have all
of our troops withdrawn is completely
out the window and we're going to stay
over there
i think the ceo of lockheed is a woman
yes jack
did i just hold on to that that's pretty
messed up so let me just say the
women who run the military industrial
complex they jumped up onto their desks
and started square dancing together
doing a jig and they're all celebrating
and clapping along i would say they
pulled up their skirts but no they
weren't
can't suit james d oh it's a guy khalsa
ceo and president he corrected you
well i want to say like i really hope
we're wrong about this too but i
basically made the exact same prediction
yeah i mean taliban promised they would
attack if we're there past may 1st as in
two weeks from now
and we're still going to stay there
longer you will you will
sweet we're staying today yeah i promise
why did they say september 10th anyway
they're obviously trying to make a
statement yeah so no september 11th yeah
that's what he said we're going to be
out there on the 20 like
right after and then right on cue
lindsey graham pops up and he's like joe
biden's making a big mistake with this
republicans have to rally together to
keep the war going forever
and then joe biden's going to be like
you know we got to have compromise come
on man the republicans you know we can't
just
take whatever we want i'm going to
compromise okay lindsay you're right
we're not going to applaud afghanistan
because we we believe in negotiating
yeah that was like three seconds when
lindsey graham had credibility
during the kavanaugh trial yeah and now
it's just gone yeah i love his
quote was that the decision was dumber
than dirt
and devilishly dangerous which is very
nice
remember that cringey means where he was
like walking like a gangster
and he looked at everyone was like oh i
couldn't stand it i thought it was great
the republican party got support because
they were forced in the trump direction
exactly
exactly the american people rejected
this no when the republican party voted
for donald trump they were rejecting
the foreign policy establishment well i
mean they were rejecting hillary clinton
right but when his movement
actual support from americans who were
going to his rallies and showing up for
him a lot of that was people who were
conservative and who were sick of the
foreign policy establishment running the
show
yep he beat 17 of those
a-holes it was a very clear statement
trump the hutt
yeah i like that metaphor that he was
like a hut because he was like
definitely
this gangster from outside trade dealing
you know doing deals
business the huts are bad people argue
and they're big nasty and fat and all
that stuff
but they weren't they weren't like
they're not the sith no they're not
force sensitive
they were they were people who were
dancing around and enjoying their time
along with them
and a lot of people were willing to do
business with business with them and
think about how even
uh uh luke skywalker approached jabba he
was like i'll give you a chance
so even the approach to the huts or to
jabba specifically was like
you know maybe we'll make a deal with
with like the sith it's like
you know obi-wan draws the lightsaber
immediately he's like i'm going to kill
anakin now that he says he's a sith a
guy i've known my whole life who's like
my brother must die
the moment he says he's a sith it's very
very different you know what i mean
now that we're doing star wars memes we
should just ask leia what she thought
yeah
yeah i have her time with the hutts how
long
was she there chained up do we know
that's a good question how long between
the end of empire in the beginning of
here no
years no no because she goes there in
the beginning of the movie and then gets
caught
she's in the disguise remember that's
right yeah and then he captures her and
she's only there for a little bit i
think
between when han got frozen in carbonite
and luke goes to
to to jabba that there was like a year
or more
had passed so who's luke in this analogy
i don't even know i
do you do definitely not no europe look
at the hair no
it's gotta be like the son of a
prominent democrat who goes rogue and
then like
tulsi gabbard man no i'm han solo like
i love it all right all right all right
should we talk about she goes and she
goes i love you and he goes
i know that was that was an improvised
line that was it well that's baller
yeah that that is real life right there
that's just harrison he stole my line
[Laughter]
apparently he was supposed to say
something like i love you too but
harrison ford was like han wouldn't say
that
no so he's like i know that was good
that was good that was classic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you